faire passer l'émotion travail et
l'interprétation pour ses voyages en
aquarelle c'est le pari de muriel
schwarz ini monteyne pour sa toute
première exposition à la maison félix de
montigny le bretonneux passionnés
d'aquarelles cet artiste en herbe part à
la conquête de ses tout premiers public
j'ai toujours aimé dessiner et mais
c'est vrai que c'est le côté doux pastel
et le rendu des aquarelles me plaisait
bien et c'est comme ça j'ai choisi de me
de prendre des cours de nos spécialisé
un petit peu là dedans au total 43
toiles sont exposées travail de
reproduction d'après des tableaux mais
aussi des photos pour un rendu plus
original enfants sous couleurs pastel
portrait de pays d'ailleurs
muriel choir s'inspire de tous les
supports pour laisser vivre son art je
les trouve très très belle très varié il
ya vraiment de tout pour tous les goûts
sur place la peintre laisse libre cours
à sa création
prochaine étape l'abstrait l'artiste
souhaite gommer les supports pour
laisser place à son imagination
l'exposition elle se poursuit jusqu'au
17 février